hey guys what's up this is andrew for
chances.com so in this video guys i am
sorry but i don't have good news
um we had a fed meeting yesterday guys
we had a 50-bit increase in the rates as
expected the guidelines were looking
good but in the end they were not that
good so let's analyze all of that and
let's see what is the situation now
let's get into it
alright guys so we're gonna start with
amc
um so it's basically it's a bloodbath
guys on uh pretty much everything all
the equity
markets um
[Music]
this is not a amc related issue so here
we have we still have this all right so
we had here the breakout that occurred
without volume increase
and like i said in my discord so
breakout above this wedge upper band so
it's not
invalidated yet right we are still in a
breakout situation as you can see we are
still i said 14.5 as a stop loss here in
my discord i know you guys don't like
stop losses but
you know
sometimes it can save your ass so
this was the trade idea i proposed
and for now we're still above that level
so um
i mean
bulls can take back control just looking
at amc but
what is not looking good guys is what is
happening on the rest of the market um
so here let me just remind you what we
are having breakout re-tests so it's
very possible we move up just looking at
amc all right we have the buddhist
divergence
we still don't have the volume so to
confirm this breakout we need to have a
move with volume on the upside and it
needs to happen soon after the breakout
so today it didn't happen maybe tomorrow
let's see it's kind of the
last chance for this breakout to give a
strong move up um
[Music]
but like i said guys
what is happening on the market is not
good so jamie what is it doing
okay so here we got rejected here
as you can see guys i did my video
yesterday and i told you that 130 is the
level to close above for boost to take
back control but that we have this trend
line
uh that acted here
as resistance
not really actually this runner was not
perfect we didn't even touch it
uh maybe on the fourth time frame i have
the aftermarket so maybe that's why i
had this trend line uh bam bam bam
so here it it worked well all right so
sometimes the aftermarket and pre-market
giving is giving you better results even
if the low volume involved in this
hours makes the signals less reliable
but here as you can see the trend line
that i draw using pre and aftermarket is
giving me a perfect reaction here and we
got here rejected so bears and control
um
i think we're going 205 maybe even 85
guys so
the reason why i'm thinking this is the
rest of the market so let's go to that i
know that you guys want to see me
discussing amc and gme i know that but
right now guys the focus is on the rest
of the market amc gme will go better and
we'll you know
make all this year you guys want on amc
and jimmy whenever we're gonna have uh
some
bullish signals on the global market
because as long as right now we're
having bad signals and as long as this
is happening amc and gm cannot fight the
rest of the market by themselves so
what happened yesterday during the fed
meeting we had a 50 bps increase
which was expected uh we're going to
have another 50 bps increase in june
another one in july we basically target
two to three percent uh rates
uh for
the inflation to start to go lower so
this is what the fed german powell is
calling the neutral rate which is the
rate where when inflation goes down but
the growth is not going down so it's
neutral right what we call stagflation
right this is what is targeted right now
so to do that he's gonna he's not gonna
increase by 75 pips which was the good
news the market saw yesterday but guys
there was no good news yesterday no good
news we just increased the rates
we have a very very tough inflation to
tackle
we have all
many things that we have no control on
we have control on the demand by
increasing rates you're gonna slow the
economy and you're gonna slow the demand
people are gonna spend less money uh but
we don't have any way to control the
supply which is lower now that's why the
price rises rise right uh supply is
lower because of kovid and war and we
have no control on that the fed cannot
do anything about that so basically we
can control the demand but not the the
supply so we don't control inflation
that's a lie the inflation is not under
control it will never be but it can
still stop going higher and go
lower we need the inflation to come back
to the you know at least below five guys
and in september after the two right
rates hike we're gonna see more clearly
what is gonna happen because if the
economy
is um i mean if the inflation is still
not under control despite that it means
that the two percent or three percent
neutral rate is actually not two or
three is higher and if we go higher guys
i don't know how the growth can sustain
so this is a recession risk and this is
what the market is pricing today
um yesterday was a dead cat bounce guys
i personally took a short position i
sent it in my discord i told you guys
that all right i still have my shot from
yesterday
and i told you guys that
you know
there was nothing to do here right
so right now you can say yeah it was a
buy seriously it was not a buy but we
still had a strong move up
uh that was just you know pure fomo
because there was no good news in
yesterday's power speech no good news
um
and i told you guys that here it was the
level to sell
so this is exactly what i did on on s
triple q which is the um
three times short etf of nasdaq
i posted an alert i said to buy here
and take half of the profits here so
today we're making good money
in my discord i make good money
i lose of course on my stocks but guys i
make good money on s triple q today so
that's very good let me just show you
that the alert was here
sorry this is the crypto bulls discord
that is growing fast by the way guys
growing really fast
i will make a video soon about that
we're gonna have this website ready guys
this is really really
fire what we're doing is amazing and we
have
i mean a very strong team very strong
plan we have uh we can see the hype
coming the discord i mean this project
will work and if you guys are still not
onboarded come now because otherwise
there's not going to be any early bull
places left for you i i'm sorry to tell
you that so right now we still have some
so if you want to grab it come now
uh whatever here
this is the alert i put it i posted so
on the 29th of april buy at 42 as you
can see
we were at 45 at that time i still had
that
and yesterday when we were at 42 here i
confirmed that the trade is valid and i
bought 330 shares
here so i make almost 2k today on this
which is really good because of course
i'm losing on the rest of my position
but today is a very good day for me
thanks to this trade but whatever
the thing is that right now what is the
situation
on triple q
it's not clear you know we are here this
level has not been respected i don't
know exactly where is the level here
uh if i use eliot wave theory i
feel that there is one more wave to come
all right the fifth one can go to 280
guys it can be very brutal all right be
prepared for that be careful if you want
to buy the deep guy we have we have
some downside that is likely to come
here
why is it likely to come is i if i only
check you know amc like i did we are
above support
jme is looking bearish now
triple q you're gonna tell me yeah but
you know maybe we're gonna have you know
by the deepest coming and just bang this
deep like they always do yes maybe
maybe not
maybe not guys here if you check s
triple q we are coming close to
resistance as you can see we have a very
nice consolidation here so for those who
have not bought any s triple q there is
one more trade to do here above this
level
if we come here then re-test here is a
buy right you can buy the breakout you
can buy the retests i mean if you have
stocks
not financial advice but if you see a
breakout above 49 guys
careful
and i'm afraid we're going to see it
because of this guys alright
i told you about that for two weeks now
the u.s 10-year yield have broken out 40
years resistance this is not something
that
you know should be ignored this is
his trick all right this
i mean sometimes a breakout is a fake
out right but if it's not a fake out
guys
this breakout once again let me explain
quickly for those who have not watched
that the u.s 10 new yield is pushed by
inflation and it's um representing the
expected return of equity over a long
period of time here 10 years the higher
it is
the less likely investors will stay in
the equity market because it's more
difficult to beat three percent than it
was to be two percent for equity
and when the when this rate is too high
usually um
there is a rotation from the equity
market to the bond market right so
people are gonna sell liquidity to buy
bonds because it yields better that's
the only reason but we still have some
reasons to believe that
um
[Music]
with a high inflation it's tough to
even if you get three percent but the
definition is eight you're still losing
five percent right so some investors
might think i'm still better off buying
some equity because at least maybe you
have the chance to beat the inflation
true if you want to beat the inflation
don't buy the us 10 yield
but
the equity market is still very high
so it's better to lose five percent
eight inflation minus three which is the
real um interest rate you get than
losing you don't know how much so some
investors think like that
turning bearish guys i've been actually
embarrassed since december i'm trying to
you know keep hope
uh but
the signal is not good to me
i told you guys there is still a chance
we just get rejected and the equity
market bounce okay
it happened there was a bounce but the
us 10 yield
almost didn't move yesterday during the
announcement i mean it went little bit
down but not big you can see
so this was the reason why to me
we went back to yesterday
too
to 90 to 90. the bracket level was 285
guess it was still above that this was
just a pullback and as you can see we
break out we pull back and we move
higher right typical breakout situation
um
of course it can be a fake out but guys
this is going higher the dxy which is
you know representing the fear of
indebted countries and companies
that rush for the dollar to pay back the
debt with increasing rates all right
this is creating tension and this is a
sign of tension this is double
information that we have here people are
scared and people and um
yeah basically the this is the
information we get people rush for the
dollar to pay back the debt so i mean
the environment is just disgusting guys
this is all i can say so
i would not buy the deep before here i
took some of my profits on triple q
already because it was a nice trade but
i'm going to keep half of my position in
case we go higher i'm i'm i hope we
won't but i'm afraid we will because i
have indicators signaling me
um for most of them that
this correction is not over
so
once again don't buy three
seven i mean not financial advice but i
wouldn't buy that level i would only be
buying at 280
so
i'm not saying this is the right trade
to do i'm just saying that whenever
triple q is at 280 i'm gonna go on
stocks and buy some dips right not
before that
and i'm waiting for a close-up of 338
which is now a bit far before turning
bullish on the equity market
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on the sub like
and bell button so you're going to be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i'll see you
guys